comme chaque année le complexe est de
monel bus à Saint-Paul organise ses
journées pores ouvertes une occasion
pour les parents de renforcer le contact
avec l'institution qui accompagne leurs
enfants tout au long de l'année ben
c'est pour visiter un peu tout ce que
les enfants fait il y a pas mal de trucs
à visiter le travail le jardin l'atelier
et tout c'est bien
intéressant ça fait un bout de temps que
j'étais au courant qu' aur cette Joinet
ben je dis bon il y a les éducateurs les
les les animateurs ils
travaillent tous les jours avec eux en
plus ils prennent sur leur temps pour
préparer cette jinée ben nous parents il
faut leur montrer notre reconnaissance
parce que on voit qu'ils aiment le
amétier et qu'ils aiment nos enfants
c'est important pour
euh pour nos pour nos enfants et en
dehors de de nos enfants c'est pour
encourager toutes ces personnes qui tous
les jours
essayent essayent de d'avancer dans la
vie donc pour moi c'est c'est un devoir
si si nous peu il faut participer c'est
ouvrir notre
structure au public extérieur euh au
partenaires pourir mieux se faire
connaître c'est également une occasion
pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore trouvé de
place pour leurs enfants ou leurs
proches de prendre connaissance de
l'ensemble des activités de
l'établissement et de prendre contact
avec les équipes de professionnels je je
suis venue visiter une fois avec le
directeur le chef et là j'ai fait la
notification DPH il est sur liste
d'attend il est encorep jusquà 2016 et
après qu place va venir
ici surtout moi le problème c'est que je
voudrais que c'est un suivi je veux pas
qu'on dit que ben il y a plus de place
il faut rester à la maison moi je
pourrais pas et moi en tant maman je
voudrais que mon enfant soit dans soit
un institut ou soit dans a ou quelque
chose qui qui puiv te suivre mais pas
rester à la maison en Joiner parce que
je pourrais pas mais bon après s'il y a
pas de
choix supporté comme dit c'est mon
enfant plusieurs activités sont prévues
des stand exposent les travaux réalisé
par les usagers et les équipes
accompagnantes parmi elles cette fresque
murale enfin c'est également l'occasion
pour le complexe ETM bus d'inaugurer
l'atelier numérique une nouvelle
activité de lesat pour les usagers c'est
également important que l'établissement
s'ouvre sur l'extérieur c'est une
occasion de montrer ce qu'il savent
faire M aujourd'hui pari les autres
mamans aussi là aujd'hui une maman là a
des mamans de tous les gens ils sont là
là très content les parents un les
autres ça ça me tousse aujourd'hui c'est
pte ouvert c'est c'est c'est affaire n
fait tous Lesens pourquoi c'est
important de que les mamans soi là parce
que les MAM c'est pour expliquer ce qu
porte ouvert parce que on peut pas parce
que quand on a des réunions comme ça les
les parents il Vinent pour porte ouvert
pour expliquer quel outils nous Man pour
tout parent voir son enfant gagner en
autonomie est une réussite en soi depuis
qu'ils sont amis en établissement
spécialisé les mamans sont unanimes
leurs enfants ont réalisé de sérieux
progrès ah oui a fait a fait beaucoup de
progrès changé là depuis à l'âge 15 ans
prend son B tout seul
ou parce au premier
début la parole changé
changé par pas du 5 an il
bloqué
5S association
associationciationourdi ah oui par parle
trop chaque fois il fallait toujours
apprendre comment faire des papiers
apprendre comment aller au devant de
tout quoi mais maintenant ça y est avec
le temps on est arrivé à mettre des
choses au point avec les éducateurs les
animateurs et tout ce qu'il y a ici les
encadrants et tout maintenant ça va
beaucoup mieux elle savait pas prendre
le bus avant mais maintenant un beau
bout de temps là elle sait prendre le
bus toute seule si le soutien des
professionnels et les progrès observés
permettent de gagner en autonomie les
mamans d'enfants porteurs de handicap
savent qu'ils ont une forte probabilité
d'avoir toujours besoin d'un
accompagnement lorsqu'on leur demande
d'envisager l'avenir de leurs enfants
porteurs de handicap il semble qu'ell
choisissent d'avancer pas à pas et de se
concentrer sur le présent je sais pas
ENCI sais pas quoi répondre pour son
avenir c'est à elle dev voir bon déjà
elle a un enfant elle l' pas su occuper
trop son l'enfant depuis la naissance
c'est moi qui est pris en main jusqu'à
maintenant parce que là je dois me
libérer pour aller une réunion pour
l'enfant aussi après vous voyez je fais
le tour la sienne est celle de l'enfant
c'est après
c'est sera je dirais après moi quand tu
auras 60 ans moi je bon je dis pas que
je ne serai plus là mais enfin peut-être
je ne seraai plus capable de
l'accompagner comme il
faut vous savez qu'on a un certain âge
on voit pas
trop trop loin comment on va après ça on
essaie de tous les jours construire avec
elle avancer au jour le jour redécouvrir
les activités réalisé en établissement
voilà aussi ce que sont les portes
ouvertes un moment pour gagner en
confiance